So now let's consider how different lock implementations
interact with the coherence protocol and what performance
do they achieve. Let's look at three cores, 0, 1, and 2. Let's first try to do
this with atomic exchange instructions. Core 0 let's
say, tries to grab the lock first. And
it succeeds. It does an atomic exchange, gets
that the lock was free. The lock var is
now going to be in the modified state in the cache of core 0. And it's going to
not be present in core 1 and core
2's caches. Now eventually core 0, which grabbed the
lock, will unlock by writing 0 to the lock var. But the question is what happens
meanwhile on core 1 and core 2? Both core 1 and core 2 might want to also enter
the same critical section. Let's say core 1 tries first. He does an exchange of
R1 and lock var, see that lock var is one. So, it didn't grab the lock, but
because there was a write to lock var, there is a transfer of lock var into this
cache, where it's now modified. And now lock var is invalid in core 0's cache.
Let's say that core 0 now does it's own
exchange. Does the same thing. Tries to grab the lock,
sees that it's one, will try again. But because it
did the write to lockvar, now it grabs the block
in the modified state and core 1 gets it in
invalid state and core 2 stays invalid. And now, as
long as the lock is busy, these two will be
spinning in that loop. So what's going to happen is
this block will move many many times between
their caches, each time causing communication on the shared
bus. And each time spending a lot of power.
None of this activity here will actually succeed in
grabbing the lock until the lockvar becomes 0.
So at some point, let's say that core 1
was the last one to grab the lock at
the point where lock lockvar is written to 0.
This write will cause yet another movement of
the block, it becomes modified in core 0's cache
now. And now, whoever tries to grab the lock
first will succeed by obtaining the block, writing to
it, but this time grabbing the lock. So,
if core one now succeeds in grabbing the lock
after it became available, core two continues this activity
further. So, there is a lot of this going
on as long as anybody's waiting on a
lock. This is very power hungry because these
movements of data between caches are going to
cost us a lot of energy per transfer.
And also, this activity here keeps the interconnect
between the course busy, for example, the shared
bus. So the one core that is actually
doing useful work here while this is going on.
If it has a cache miss will now be
slower in handling this cache miss because it has
to wait for the busy bus that these two
are keeping busy. So not only is it power
hungry to do this, it also by busy waiting
in such an active way we're slowing down the
useful work that is the only thing that can
really result in us actually getting the lock eventually.